left side in the fourth row again
Michael clay Michael Grange from Sports
Net whenever you ready over here clay
defensively you you look like you were
pretty successful in limiting Kawhi
Leonard what was your you're thinking a
strategy regarding that and how do you
think the Raptors were able to to take
advantage of that of whatever that
strategy was I mean Kauai didn't have
his best game their standards but other
guys stepped up I mean see Aachen
obviously had the game of his playoff
life give him credit run of the floor so
we'll have to get back on defense next
game and really limit their transition
points make us beat make them beat us
and a half court and yeah we did a good
job with mean Kauai but it's not quite
Leonard and it's the Raptors so we'll go
back to the drawing board and see we can
do better for Sunday thank you other
questions
second row here on the left the mark
clay Steve mark Schwartz ESPN Steve
mentioned that you guys are not that
familiar with the Raptors you don't see
them a lot how surprising was what see
Ockham's athleticism enabled him to do
in transition tonight I mean he's very
long and athletic he's one of the better
finishers in the paint in the game so I
know we'll stop with the challenge on
Sunday to limit his opportunities which
a lot of them came in transition because
he was sprinting the floor but yeah
we're not very familiar with this team
but that's no excuse
you know it's still a so got to come out
here and our goal was to get one and
it's still on the table for us so I know
we respond like the champions we are
left side fifth row the Rasch clay right
here on the on the aisle reshma dating
with Sports Net you guys your DNA as a
team is
ignite with with big runs points and
bunches you weren't able to do that
tonight it really at any stretch why do
you think that may have been I mean we
cut it to three with about seven minutes
left or eight nine minutes left whatever
it was and you know get their defense
credit we didn't get too many transition
opportunities and what our best weren't
running and playing with this type of
randomness that kind of has teams
scrambling and it was there a little bit
tonight but um like I said before our
goal was to get one so we got some tape
now and we'll go to the drawing board
and we'll come back and be much better
on Sunday any other questions Thank You
clay
[Music]